madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition en france un cas suspect de
vache folle l'animal a été découverte
dans un abattoir sans certificat
vétérinaire échappant au dispositif de
sécurité une enquête est en cours
dominique venner france la tempête des
verts les militants et les cadres n'ont
pas mâché leurs mots après les erreurs
de communication sur la marée noire la
ministre a joué l'apaisement
les vacances d'hiver avec cet exemple
pour l'instant unique en france d'une
station qui fixe ses prix en fonction de
la feuille d'impôt de chacun la
consécration des patineurs français
marina anissina et gwendal peizerat
champion d'europe portrait de ce duo en
or
une histoire à fait raison cette affaire
particulièrement préoccupante avec la
découverte près de pontivy dans le
morbihan d'une vache présentant tous les
signes de l'un ses fans au pâtis
spongiforme bovine dans un abattoir une
découverte presque par hasard de cet
animal qui n'avait aucun certificat
vétérinaire autrement dit ils étaient
passés à travers le dispositif de
sécurité
la bête donc vendu sur un marché par un
agriculteur du finistère étaient
destinés à la consommation
une enquête a été ouverte de nombreuses
questions restent dans l'ombre note
aline raison c'est dans cet abattoir que
les inspecteurs de la division des
services vétérinaires ont découvert
jeudi une vache suspecte un animal
présentant des signes proches de ceux de
l'encéphalopathie spongiforme bovine et
fait étonnant la bête ne présentait pas
de certificat vétérinaire
or c'est obligatoire pour les animaux
malades pour quelle raison ce que devra
déterminer l'enquêté de la gendarmerie
soit l'animal n'était
absolument pas en malade en quittant la
ferme
par exemple il a pu être blessés au
cours du transport soit deuxième
possibilité bien sûr on a voulu se
débarrasser d'une bête qui a été malade
mais à ce moment là
notons beurion et c'est le seul cas le
seul moment où tomberions de
l'infraction pénale et leur quête nous
renseignera sur ce point l'agriculteur
qui a vendu la bête à l'abattoir
auraient pu dissimuler la maladie pour
ne pas avoir aligné tout son troupeau
mais il ne s'agit que d'une hypothèse
les prélèvements par ailleurs été
effectués sur la vache abattue et
envoyés au laboratoire de l'agencé
française de sécurité sanitaire des
aliments
aujourd'hui nous en sommes quand ce
n'est qu'une suspicion de sb qu'est le
diagnostic ne pourra être que confirmer
ou infirmer par l'examen de laboratoire
qui est fait par les laboratoires de
pathologie bovine à lyon pour le
ministère de l'agriculture cette affaire
n'est pas alarmante celle prouve au
contraire que le système de contrôle mis
en place pour détecter les cas de sb
fonctionne bien et la marée noire
souffle en tempête sur les cadres et les
militants du parti des verts réunis
aujourd'hui en conseil national
interrégional dominique voynet après
avoir essuyé une salve de critiques
chacun dans une sorte de happening a
vidé son sac et son coeur la ministre de
l'environnement comme souvent n'est
jamais aussi performante que dans
l'adversité et finalement a su rassurer
ses troupes allemandes nicosie frédéric
faure des applaudissements des sourires
et même des bisous à son arrivée
dominique voynet affiche volontiers sa
sérénité
alors qu'elle sait que les moments qui
vont suivre seront parfois délicat
nos défaillances politique par rapport à
la gestion de la catastrophe de l'erika
couver depuis plus longtemps et que ça
n'a été qu'un révélateur ans comme noël
mamère tout l'après-midi les verts se
sont livrés à une séance de psychanalyse
de groupe unique
trente trois orateurs volontaires qui
veulent tous t'expliquer pourquoi leur
avis le naufrage de l'erika a donné lieu
à un tel cafouillage chez les verts
extraits et je pense qu'effectivement
quand on joue avec le feu des médias
faut pas s'étonner de s'y brûler les
ailes ça c'est ce que faisait
régulièrement le ps avant le congrès de
raids et c'est comme ça que le ps s'est
auto assassiné j'aimerais bien qu'on ne
soit pas obligé de passer par un combat
dur est de 2,2 m un corps radio elle est
alors puisque dominique s'est réservé le
droit de parler après tout le monde je
lui posais une question très simple
c est ce que cette culture de
gouvernement là nous allons la traînée
comme un boulet jusqu'aux
présidentielles avec le coût que cela
aura parfois donc de manière explicite
dominique voynet est visé et à travers
elle la participation des verts au
gouvernement alors la ministre de
l'environnement va ré expliquer
l'intérêt qu'il accorde à cette fonction
mais sans en cacher les difficultés
petit lire et dominique voynet
j'ai eu souvent l'occasion de dire que
je trouvais inconfortable et
impraticable ne devoir assumer
simultanément une responsabilité
gouvernementale avec tout ce que ça
suppose de solidarité gouvernementale et
une fonction de fêtes de porte parole
chez les verts en exposant ainsi ses
doutes ses joies mais aussi ses
déceptions au gouvernement dominique
voynet a semble-t-il convaincu qu'elle
ne reniait pas ses idées originelles et
qu'il fallait rendre à l'épisode de
l'erika une dimension plus réduite dans
l'histoire du parti et de nouveaux
développements tout juste deux mois
après le naufrage du pétrolier erika
avec cette enquête qui remonte à la
source savoir ou plutôt tenter de savoir
à quels sites étaient vraiment destiné
le fuel acheminés dans les soutes du
tanker affrété par total fina est une
nouvelle fois la vérité n'est pas
toujours limpide puisque apparemment ce
chargement officiellement destinée à une
centrale électrique denis bourde aurait
pu en réalité avoir comme point de chute
celle de milazzo au nord de
si celle enquête patrick fandio abdel
juillet cette fois même la presse locale
en a fait ses gros titres
sans doute parce que l'homme qui
accusent et un militant écologiste bien
connu en sicile mais surtout parce qu'il
affirme que l'entreprise publique
italienne enel a menti sur la
destination du fioul de l'erika car
officiellement la cargaison par de
dunkerque le 8 décembre 99
elle est attendu ici à la centrale
électrique de piombino dans la région de
niveau elle se sert de ce fioul comme
combustible une énergie bon marché à
piombino les responsables de la centrale
plusieurs fois sollicité n'ont pas
souhaité nous rencontrer nous aurions
souhaité avoir la confirmation que le
pétrole de l'erika était bien attention
car d'après ce document de total une des
pièces de l' enquête administrative
le fuel avait une toute autre
destination milazzo en sicile une
centrale électrique surveiller de très
près depuis dix ans par giuseppe
ruggieri et son mouvement les gammes gmt
pour lui le site est réputé pour brûler
des résidus de fioul lourd toxique et
dangereux les fuels qu'on a l'habitude
de brûler dans cette centrale
quand une concentration souvent et
parfois très élevé d'après moi et en
l'absence de tout dispositif pour
extraire le souffle ce sont des fuels
dangereux aussi bien pour la santé des
populations que pour l'environnement
en plus c'est une centrale qui est
située en pleine zone d'habitations une
centrale à situer doit être corps et le
fioul de l'erika était-il un de ceux que
les gammes bien été comparé à des
déchets pétroliers
l'association affirme ne pas le savoir
dans un communiqué de presse
enel précise n'avoir commandé qu'un fuel
numéro deux standards et rien d'autre
l'entreprise italienne précise qu'elle
n'a de toutes les façons aucune manière
de mettre en doute la cargaison
et pour cause et ne lui est jamais
parvenu
la bataille pour obtenir coûte que coûte
de nouveaux postes d'enseignants dans
les écoles maternelles et primaires du
département de l'hérault cette bataille
ne faiblit pas dix mille personnes
autant d'enseignants que de parents
d'élèves ont une nouvelle fois uni leurs
forces pour réclamer dans les rues de
montpellier
cette école de qualité qui selon eux
passent forcément par des affectations
supplémentaires cette manifestation
s'inscrit deux jours après les premiers
arbitrages sur la fameuse carte scolaire
rendue publique par l'éducation
nationale véronique gallienne donné par
dano les panneaux ne sont pas assez
larges pour contenir leur colère l'an
dernier déjà ils n'ont pas obtenu de
postes supplémentaires pour l'école
cette année ils ne se laisseront pas
oublié on est dans un petit village il
ya des choses obligatoire comme par
exemple informatique et l'anglais et non
les autres thèmes on les obtient pas à
saint jean de cornies la population
augmente de façon constante
mais l'école maternelle et primaire ne
compte toujours que trois classes
regroupant chacune trois niveaux pour
arriver à motiver chaque groupe et donc
il faut beaucoup d'énergie il faut
beaucoup de disponibilité quand les
enfants sont petits faut souvent répété
fois disponible faut être présent et
avec 32 enfants dans la classe ça
devient difficile quoi il ya des choses
sur lesquelles on passe plus et on a on
a moins de temps chacun avec sa colère
chacun avec son panneau chaque village
chaque quartier est descendue dans les
rues de montpellier
en tout ils étaient dix mille parents et
enseignants pour demander une autre
école
mais à nous à râler on espère nous faire
entendre pour dire que ça suffit pas
forcément de qualité comme ça on ne peut
pas continuer dans des conditions de
pire en pire soit possible main des 630
passe à l'académie dans l'hérault et où
nous savons que 78 camps l'académie
trois kilomètres de cortège et surtout
le sentiment d'être incompris et
mépriser les manifestants ont parcouru
dans le calme les rues du centre-ville
ralentissant devant un rectorat aux
portes closes
il se jurant qu si cette fois ils ne
sont pas entendus
l'indicé sur le mouvement continue à
strasbourg venus par bus de différents
pays d'europe mais aussi de toute la
france cette manifestation de kurdes
un an après l'arrestation d'abdullah
ocalan les organisateurs demandent la
libération du leader kurde mais aussi la
démocratisation de la thur pif
depuis midi entre 15 et 20 minutes reste
en ce sens on peut rassembler pendant
plusieurs heures dans le centre de la
ville en fin de journée le cortège s'est
retrouvé pour un meeting avec chants et
danses en l'honneur du kurdistan
difficile de savoir avec précision
comment évolue le conflit en tchétchénie
selon différents témoignages plusieurs
centaines de personnes auraient été
tuées dans des bombardements au sud-est
de la capitale désormais la guerre se
déplace en particulier vers les
montagnes du sud où seraient réfugiés
prêtes à en découdre
les indépendantistes tchétchènes
dorothée olliéric et didier deshamps ont
pu le constater en suivant sous bonne
escorte est totalement encadrés pendant
24 heures un bataillon russe qui se
rendaient vers le sud
c'est un chant de marin qui parle de
bagarres d'alcool et de femmes nous
sommes à grozny les soldats attendent le
départ de l'hélicoptère qui doit les
emmener vers la ligne de front
ils partent à la guerre encore une fois
après gros sous leur nouveau champ de
bataille c'est la zone montagneuse dans
les gorges dargaud après un quart
d'heure d'hélicoptère
ils vont rejoindre leurs positions
entassés sur un char d'assaut les forces
fédérales russes tiennent cette base
depuis une quinzaine de jours ils ont
chassé les combattants tchétchènes d'ici
mais l'ennemi n'est pas loin la ligne de
front et de l'autre côté à 404 ici voyez
les maisons détruites ya les tchétchènes
dedans
chaque jour des soldats partent en
éclaireur pour repérer les nouvelles
positions des policiers on a déjà pris
grozny maintenant on va déloger les
tubes attendant les chaînes de ces
montagnes pour eux la guerre est devenue
une routine la peur ces gosses de 20 ans
dans par le pas et pourtant aujourd'hui
un de leur camarade a perdu la vie ces
champs de boue sont infestés de mime
technique ce qui est le plus difficile
pour nous dans ce genre de terrain c'est
que les chars ne pas cela il faut dire
aussi que les combattants tchétchènes
sont dans leur fief
ici la montagne ils connaissent
ici des centaines de combattants
islamistes étrangers auraient été formés
par chamil bassaïev
selon les soldats ils sont aussi dans
les montagnes ces dernières 24 heures
les forces fédérales russes on en sait
plus de 200 raids aériens dans cette
zone de montagnes là bas sont retranchés
quelques 7000 combattants tchétchènes
l'objectif des russes et les déloger et
il compte engager très vite une
offensive terrestre massive avec plus de
cinquante mille hommes et puis ces
images mais cette fois ci du côté des
forces tchétchènes avec cette vidéo
tournée de nuit montrant des combattants
réfugiés dans les montagnes solidement
armés et prêts à l'affrontement avec les
troupes russes
il sera entre sept et huit mille avoir
pris le maquis aviez une nouvelle
manifestation contre la coalition
gouvernementale qu'il nie les
conservatoires et l'extrême droite
près de dix mille personnes ont défilé
dans le calme dans le centre de la ville
essentiellement des jeunes qui
répondaient à l'appel de différents
syndicats et de mouvements de gauche
d'autres villes comme innsbruck l'x ou
feldkirch ont connu de semblables
manifestations tout au long de cette
journée
pollution majeure qui touche le nord de
la yougoslavie jusqu'à la frontière
hongroise des traces de cyanure dans les
cours d'eau des rivières provenant d'une
mine d'or roumaine rendant bien
évidemment impossible toute consommation
d'eau et de poissons romuald non non ce
n'est pas une pêche miraculeuse et pour
les habitants de ce petit village serbe
c'est même la catastrophe sur leur vieux
ce matin des milliers de poissons morts
empoisonnés au cyanure
vers 10 heures on a vu les premiers
poissons morts il y en a eu de plus en
plus alors que les gros agoniser les
petits sont morts tout de suite cette
catastrophe va polluer la tisza pendant
des années une pollution dont l'origine
se situe à plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres en amont près de baia mare et
en roumanie accusée une mine d'or qui
utilisent le cyanure pour nettoyer le
minerai il ya quatre jours cent mille
mètres cubes d'eau polluée se seraient
déversés dans la rivière
très vite le produit toxique s'est
répandue également en hongrie au sud du
pays
des concentrations de cyanure 800 fois
supérieur à la norme ont été relevés
les autorités hongroises ont interdit
l'utilisation de l'eau et toute
consommation de poissons ne jamais vu
des dégâts aussi grave en 30 ans de
carrière des caisses publiques a jamais
vu une telle concentration de produits
de leur côté les dirigeants de la
société australienne esmeralda
propriétaire de la mine ont nié toute
responsabilité pour les causes sont
ailleurs hier la hongrie a demandé
réparation à la roumanie
les astronautes de la navette endeavour
qui est parti hier de fleurier les
astronautes ont commencé à mettre en
place un important dispositif pour
tracer la cartographie de la terre une
structure immense érigé en apesanteur il
s'agit d'un mât télescopique de soixante
mètres équipé d'une antenne radar qui
permettra de photographier la surface
terrestre en trois dimensions il se
passe toujours avec ce télescope
européen baptisé xml lancé en décembre
dernier par la fusée ariane 5
voici ses premiers clichés plus que
satisfaisant selon les spécialistes
premier album photos de ces amas de
galaxies abdel mostefa et christian
galley quand on envoie dans l'espace le
plus puissant des télescopes sensible
aux rayons x de l'histoire de
l'astronomie en attend de lui qu'il vous
fasse quelques petites révélations
pour ces premiers clichés xmm newton n'a
pas déçu ses concepteurs à chaque prise
de vue ça a été un coup gagnant
le plus de ce bijou de technologie la
possibilité de capter des ondes
lumineuses invisible pour les optiques
classique comme celle du télescope
cette fois bon point de ce satellite
dans une direction de l'espace on
découvre de nouveaux objets qu'ils
n'étaient pas observée jusqu alors parce
que leurs températures sont trop élevés
ou pouvoir être détectées par d'autres
télescopes lors de ces tests newton a
braqué ses objectifs vers trois régions
de l'univers il a permis aux
scientifiques de découvrir une centaine
d'objets célestes non répertorié jusqu'à
présent de la matière à plusieurs
millions de degrés dans un univers plus
chaud et plus violent qu'on ne le
pensait univers que vous voyez à travers
un télescope comme celui de xmm newton
c'est un univers qu'on caractériserait
par des cataclysmes des explosions par
la voracité des toiles qui on dévore
d'autre part des galaxies qui ces
collisions avec d'autres galaxies
c'est un enfer c'était vraiment un
univers infernal
difficile d'imaginer un enfer au dessus
de nos têtes par une nuit étoilée au
moins d'août et pourtant cette partie du
ciel observé par newton par exemple le
grand nuage de magellan vat entré en
collision avec notre galaxie
mais pas de panique ce sera dans
quelques milliards d'années
aux états unis où se multiplient avec un
an quan incomparable succès les
prédicateurs présentation d'une nouvelle
apparition en robe de bure le jeune
homme qui marche pieds nus dans des
sandales de cuir suscite en pennsylvanie
la ferveur mystique un prophète qui joue
sur les ressemblances et ça marche
etienne leenhardt incontestablement il
faut du courage pour arpenter pieds nus
les routes enneigées de pennsylvanie
difficile de dire qui ce jeune homme
vêtu d'une robe immaculée et d'une
simple couverture et oui ou non un
illuminé le fait est que depuis qu'il a
débarqué ici il ya quatre mois il a
changé pas mal de choses
le voici à la maison de retraite ou les
personnes âgées l'attend depuis
plusieurs il se fait appeler quel est
ton nom
nul ne sait d'où il vient il ne demande
ni argent ni compensation d'aucune sorte
bref un vrai don du ciel venait ici vous
ne trouvez pas qu'il ressemble à jésus
même si vous n'êtes pas croyant vous
êtes obligé de reconnaître qu'il ya
quelque chose de particulier
j'étais sur la route cette ville un
passé religieux très fort et puis dieu
seul sait pourquoi c'est ici que je me
suis arrêté et la petite ville de halton
où les 23 églises ne faisait plus le
plein depuis belle lurette et soudain
prise d'une fièvre mystique peu commun
centaines de personnes veulent voir quel
est ton nom le toucher la rumeur lui
attribue des miracles évidemment avec
fiable on veut lui confier proche malade
et pennebaker
les jeunes à qui il parle de ce qui les
encourage à l'aide alors on verra bien
on est à une époque où tout le monde se
dit jésus revient il revient et les gens
se sont jetés sur cette apparition
c'est peut-être lui c'est peut-être lui
et au rythme où vont les choses aux
états unis les mauvais esprits prédisent
déjà que ce bienfaiteur une fois la
curiosité passé au tombera vite dans
l'anonymat
quant aux âmes charitables elle le voit
pourquoi pas embrasser rapidement une
derrière télévisée d'animateurs
évangélistes ou sa couverture blanche
fera sans doute fureur en france la
route des vacances circulation fume
depuis cet après midi pour ça s'est
croisé vers les stations de sports
d'hiver
une journée classée orange par bison
fûté quelques kilomètres de bouchons
dans la vallée de la tarentaise en
direction de chamonix nous sommes
intéressés en cette période de vacances
d'hiver au matériel de plus en plus
sophistiqués sachant que 70 % des skis
sur le marché sont destinés à la
location pourtant parmi les causes
toujours aussi fréquente d'accident le
mauvais réglage des fixations tu parce
qu'elle joue c'est bon les greniers pour
lui les vacances sont terminées il
n'allait pas très vite quand il est
tombé mais n'a pas déchaussé pour autant
fois de secouriste sa fixation de
location était mal réglé malgré les
progrès récents dans le domaine mais
pour vous cette jeune fille elle n'a pas
connu l'époque héroïque
quand louer son matériel signifiait
endurer les pires douleurs dans des
chaussures et sur des skis usé jusqu'à
la corde
les choses ont bien changé aujourd'hui
ce loueur a même investi plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de francs dans des
étagères chauffantes et désinfectante et
surtout il propose du haut de gamme
jusque là réservée exclusivement à la
vente c'est un ski qui fait un peu plus
de 3000 francs sans fixation et le
client qui a envie d'un ski tout neige
toute piste piste et hors piste il va se
régaler avec un ski comme ça et c'est
une chose qui ne pouvait pas trouver en
location et quelques années en arrière
votre poids s'il vous plaît meilleur
matériel meilleurs réglages
votre oeil là où seul le poids était
prise en compte il ya quelques années le
schiemann rentrent désormais cinq ou six
critères dans son ordinateur réglage
optimal quelle que soit la fluence est
donc le rythme des locations l'ennui
c'est que tous les joueurs n'ont pas
atteint ce niveau loin de là
or le score français lui s'en remettent
entièrement aux professionnels est ce
que vous le loup et vos skis est-ce que
vous avez confiance dans leur fixation
vous êtes sûrs qu'elles sont bien réglés
j'ai confiance parce que c'est de la
bonne gamme et puis que s'est entretenu
régulièrement
j'espère du moins un certain nombre de
normes pour les réglages de fixation l
heure actuelle si on prend des skieurs
sur la piste il y en a presque un sur
deux qui est hors des normes soit au
dessus soit en dessous
c'est vrai que quand on a affaire à des
locations qui loue un petit peu vite et
bien il faut absolument vérifier qu'on
vous pose les bonnes questions et qu'on
tient compte je dirais que le réglage il
est personnalisé autrement dit les
skieurs doivent progresser dans leur
connaissance du matériel
quant à leurs facéties il en garde
l'entière responsabilité
d'ailleurs présent cette initiative
unique en son genre dans la station des
karellis près de saint jean de maurienne
en savoie les prix du séjour à la neige
sont calculées selon sa feuille d'impôts
le système d'une station coopérative
reportage mary pierce amitié dominique
bonnet si les dufour offrent à leurs
cinq enfants un bol d'air aux sports
d'hiver
c'est d'abord parce qu'ils ont économisé
tous les mois on met de l'argent de côté
pour pouvoir partir aussi une semaine
combien chaque humain en 2000 francs
ensuite c'est parce qu'ici les tarifs
sont dégressifs
il s'adapte aux revenus des familles
quant aux forcé ils sont compris dans le
prix du séjour ils reviennent à 40
francs par jour dans toute la station
l'ambiance est à la simplicité à la mode
les gens viennent à poitiers vienne pas
là pour se montrer pour calculer le
montant du séjour la station réclame la
feuille d'impôt de l'année précédente et
se base sur le quotient familial
résultat les dufour vont payer leur
séjour en pension complète
plus les remontées mécaniques incluse
une facture de 14 mille 700 francs pour
huit personnes
ce qui vraiment mais les sports d'hiver
sur la haute saison en est quand même ce
à des tarifs de haute saison à la portée
de du plus grand nombre
ici le steak frites est à 35 francs et
si les commerces proposent des tarifs si
bas c'est parce qu'ils sont gérés par
une coopérative un système unique en
france les responsables des différents
magasins de la station on voit derrière
nous sont en fait également des salariés
de cette société coopérative
chaque année les bénéfices de cette
coopérative sont réinvestis dans les
équipements en 2001 on construira 300
lits supplémentaires
quant à l'école de ski français elle a
accepté d'adapter ses tarifs en ce
moment nous sommes à 400 francs je porte
toujours pour les adultes et 80 francs
pour les enfants toujours du temps des
pronostics le comex 38 enfants nés
station compte seulement deux mille six
cents lits au total 120 milles vacances
ils viennent ici chaque année on affiche
complet
il n'y aura pas de place pour tout le
monde
la consécration des patineurs français
marina anissina et gwendal peizerat avec
ce titre de champion d'europe que la
france attendait depuis 40 ans voici
comment ces rencontres et ce duo qui
porte les espoirs de la danse sur glace
une belle histoire que nous raconte
nathanaël de rincquesen ils ont les
cheveux longs et de la suite dans les
idées
marina la moscovite gwendal le lyonnais
viennent de conquérir leur premier titre
majeur sept ans après leur première
rencontre il ne compte pas s'arrêter là
en 1993 le couple franco russe effectue
ses premiers pas sur la patinoire de
lyon à cette époque gwendal a les
cheveux courts
marina elle est toujours rude mais elle
sait déjà ce qu'elle veut et commence à
se débrouiller en français
marina obtient la nationalité française
en 1995
l'histoire du couple anissina pèsera
peut commencer une belle histoire mais
une drôle d'histoire qui débute en 92
gwendal peizerat est étudiant en fac de
sciences à villeurbanne sur la glace il
danse avec marina morel
les deux français forment d'ailleurs un
des meilleurs couples européens
cette année-là morel et pèsera se classe
2e des championnats du monde juste
derrière le couple russe composé d'îles
et averbukh et d'une certaine marina
anissina l'histoire s'accélère
marina la russe et gwendal le français
se retrouve sans partenaire ils vont
s'unir sur la glace par courrier
interposé
dès lors ils ne vont plus quittés et
progresser jusqu'à ce titre européen
conquis hier soir à vienne en attendant
mieux peut-être le mois prochain au
mondial denis
à paris à la porte de versailles le
salon rétromobile l'occasion de vous
faire découvrir cette collection de 300
voitures anciennes dans ce petit village
au sud de rennes où chacun vit à travers
sept patients luc baziz un code-barres
né dans ce petit village du les vilaines
lohéac
les 650 habitants ne s'étonne jamais
devoir passer une cadillac une de la
haye où il ferra rythme normal
le coeur de la commune bat au rythme de
l'automobile un manoir est consacrée à
nos ancêtres sur 4 euros 80 mille
visiteurs viennent là chaque année pour
voyager dans le temps
à l'origine de ce projet cet homme
michel hommell arrivé il ya 25 ans sa
passion automobile a pris ici des
allures de contagion
les actes maintenant une activité
intense au dessus au niveau de
l'automobile puisque nous avons donc un
garagiste un carrossier un cellier on a
maintenant tout un environnement
d'artisans qui donc connaissent bien le
la construction automobile et sa
restauration
on est dans une voiture qui a été
parfaitement restaurés et ça aussi ça
fait partie du plaisir entre les mains
de ces deux hommes 300 véhicules anciens
ont trouvé une nouvelle jeunesse avant
de prendre le chemin du musée de lohéac
façon le yak les voitures c'est tout moi
j'ai trouvé ma place parce que j'adore
les voitures déjà d'une et après le
métier c'était de les réparer donc sur
profus chacun trouve donc sa place même
cette grand-mère né en 1899
une de dion bouton la doyenne des lieux
un peu plus loin la ford-t récemment
élue voiture du siècle mais le début de
l'automobile et du bourg de la
collection pour michel hommell c'est
cette renault n acheter 40 francs c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque je vais pas de
logique mais disons j'achetais ce qui se
présentait la c4 et dans ce musée
je les achetais 100 francs l'époque la
cref le 5000 francs c'est vrai qu'on se
souvient des prix et puis ça a duré
quarante ans aujourd'hui le patrimoine
automobile de lohéac s'enrichit d'un
nouveau né et inspirer de cette alpines
dans cet atelier il s'agit bien un
véhicule moderne en fabrication
michel hommell lui a donné son nom à ce
jour 150 exemplaires ont trouvé preneur
l'avenir du village semble assuré le
prince rainier de monaco a subi une
nouvelle opération la nuit dernière
cette fois ci l'ait mise en place de
drains dans la cage thoracique après un
pneumothorax il s'agit de la troisième
intervention en moins de deux mois la
disparition d'une haute figure de
l'aviation jacqueline auriol la première
femme pilote d'essai belle fille du
président de la république vincent
auriol est décédé hier à l'âge de 82 ans
laurence de cherves elle a été la
première femme à franchir le mur du son
jacqueline auriol belle fille du
président vincent auriol a marqué
l'histoire de l'aviation par une série
de records de vitesse
malgré un terrible accident à bord d'un
hydravion en 1949
jacqueline devient la première femme
pilote d'essai elle s'impose dans cette
discipline jusque là réservés aux hommes
ses exploits lui valu une renommée
internationale 8 118 km heure aux
commandes avant pied en 1951 et dix ans
plus tard plus de 2000 km heure sur un
mirage iii des exploits qui n'ont rien
de gratuit pour prendre sur le plan
national c'est important
pour le matériel d'une part c'est à dire
pour homologuer d'une façon tout à fait
évidente les performances d'un avion et
tout peut-être aussi sur le plan humain
faut que l'on connaisse certains jeunes
il est indispensable pour que vous le
plus de jeunes possible au service venir
à l'aviation
entre 1950 et 1960 jacqueline auriol
rivalise avec une autre jacqueline
l'aviatrice jacqueline cochrane elle se
volent les records mais deviennent des
amis une centaine d'appareils tester 20
ans de pilotage sur les avions les plus
rapides
elle est en 1975 chargé de mission au
ministère de la coopération
jacqueline auriol fut un modèle pour
plusieurs générations de femmes
elle fut surtout l'une des héroïnes
d'une étape capitale pour l'aéronautique
le passage aux vitesses supersoniques et
puis le chanteur et pianiste américain
screaming jay hawkins auteur de la
célèbre chanson à écouter ce dernier est
mort à paris à l'âge de 70 ans
marseille capitale du rap pour un soir
est le meilleur du rap puisque se réunir
en sur la scène de la plus grande de
salle de concert de la ville les
meilleurs groupes qu'il soit parisien
aux phocéens l'occasion de constater que
les rappeurs ont un sacré métier qu'ils
ont fait du chemin et qu'ils font
désormais partie intégrante du monde du
spectacle
les rappeurs sont devenus adultes
michaël darmon jean françois bramard
vous suivrez odom c'est très beau
concert ça fait 15 ans qu'on est dans le
métier ça fait 15 ans qu'on a on
contourne qu'on a qu'on voit nos
contrats comment se défile du poids des
mots au nombre de photos à marseille les
enfants de la tribu d'akhenaton le père
d'iam prennent leur envol
ils ont pour nos troisième et y fonde
qui family ou faf larage ici la planète
rap tournent de plus en plus vite
mais aujourd'hui les révoltés assure
cela pose organisera comme les plaques
panthères prêt à défendre ma cause et
les frères justesse commentant sa
business c'est un peu dur à dire mais
c'est vrai que l'europe maintenant ils
touchent beaucoup de jeunes et c'est
vrai que c'est plus comme avant et c'est
plein de trucs les brémois sas quand tu
débutes dans mon camp je commence à
écrire des textes soumis sinon des
textes intelligents et des trucs ça fait
partie de la musique
or elle est toujours autant musique de
révolte mais un peu plus calme une
révolte me dire que c'est une révolte
plus réfléchie maintenant arsenic
vedette du rap parisien deux cent mille
disques vendus et la promenade à
marseille du côté de la canebière ne
passe pas inaperçu ce qui pour vous
piscine
le total look
puis c'est tout cas c'est tout mais
avant le concert une petite visite au
rayon disent que s'imposent les affaires
sont les affaires
les gens ne peut pas nous reprocher de
faire de l'argent avec ce qu'on fait
déjà pas de joindre un plombier pourquoi
ils gagnent de l'argent nous c'est notre
métier ce soir au dôme ce sera la dream
team rappeur marseillais et parisiens
vont se réunir devant 8000 personnes
pour montrer qu'il joue sur la scène des
grands l'une des grandes de chorégraphe
américaine trisha brown a pour la
première fois que c'était une de ses
oeuvres entre au répertoire d'une
compagnie autre que la sienne spectacle
produit sur la scène de l'opéra de lyon
michel soulève ici marie pierre
cassignard
lyon et les danseurs du ballet sont à
ses pieds la grande chorégraphe trisha
brown vient apporter la touche finale à
la représentation d'une de ses oeuvres
majeures une entrée au répertoire impose
une attention de tous les instants pour
chacun des gestes pour chacune des
pauses afin d'obtenir les ans et la
grâce c'est bien si vous avez
l'impression que c'était plus facile
ce n'est pas un psychopathe il faut être
relâchés quand même se tenir
de grandes toiles lumineuses ponctue sa
chorégraphie
les danseurs deviennent éléments d'une
peinture en mouvement
le carré de la seine l'axé comme le
cadre pour le peintre c'est comme une
page de mon carnet sp l'espace est un
élément premier pour les chorégraphe
trisha brown joue à varier les
dimensions de son spectacle elle
restreint ou agrandi les espaces de
danse pourront changer les rythmes tout
varices sont extrêmement vives
extrêmement et ça donne beaucoup de
dynamisme
lorsqu'on voit les danseurs évoluer par
suez
les corps sont magnifiques la tension
qui peut y avoir entre entre les couples
entre les les différents groupes de
danseurs c'est extrêmement émouvant et
les duos sont au coeur de ce ballet
c'est de l'amour dont nous parle la
chorégraphe premier festival
international du film de l'ue chance
serait évitée le sindh en compétition
trois été coproduit par france 2 notre
scène a été deux fois récompensé pour la
petite absente réalisé par josé pinheiro
qui a reçu le prix du public et que vous
pourrez voir mercredi prochain 20 heures
cinq ans d'autre part le prix de la
presse a été attribué à anna en corse
avec romane bohringer surtout sa fin de
ce journal je vous en rappelle les deux
principaux titres en france un cas
suspect de vache folle
l'animal a été découvert dans un
abattoir sans certificat vétérinaire
échappant au dispositif de sécurité
une enquête est en cours la bataille
pour obtenir coûte que coûte de nouveaux
postes d'enseignants dans les écoles
maternelles et primaires du département
de l'hérault ne faiblit pas dix mille
personnes dans les rues de montpellier
dans un instant la météo patrice drevet
20h55 le plus grand cabaret du monde
présenté par patrick sébastien
1h20 le dernier journal laurence
ostolaza de master dans thé ou café
catherine ceylac reçoit judith magre à
midi d emma l'émission de paul amar
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain dès 13 heures je vous remercie de
votre attention excellente fin de soirée
sur france 2